imagina que tenemos dos personas las
cuales de una manera colectiva van a
empujar una caja a través de la nieve
hasta llegar a la meta así que vamos a
decir que tenemos aquí por aquí voy a
dibujar a mi caja esta de aquí va a ser
mi caja ok y la vamos a empujar a través
de la nieve hasta llegar a la meta así
que déjenme poner aunque por aquí tengo
la meta ok
esta es la meta de lujo ahora la persona
y bueno es que de alguna manera extraña
no pueden empujar justo detrás de la
caja no sé tal vez no hay una buena base
de apoyo o tal vez se resbale la caja
qué sé yo así que la persona am va a
empujar la caja en una dirección la cual
no es exactamente la dirección hacia la
meta así que se me ocurren y vamos a
cambiar de color para hablar de la
persona am se me ocurre que la persona
va a empujar esta caja de esta cierta
manera y aquí va a empezar y la va a
empujar
así va a empujar a la caja con esta
dirección y techo este va a ser mi
vector fuerza este va a ser mi vector
fuerza de la persona am porque este
vector me va a decir la dirección a la
cual está empujando la persona a esta
caja y además sabemos también es un dato
que nos dan que la magnitud la magnitud
de este vector fuerza am este vector
fuerza de la persona am es exactamente
igual a 330 newtons ok bueno esto para
la persona am pero también tenemos a la
persona ve y por otra parte la persona
ve también va a empujar la caja pero
tampoco la puede empujar desde atrás
vamos a suponer que esta caja por aquí
está bastante húmeda y por lo tanto es
bastante resbaloso empujar esta caja
desde su parte trasera y entonces la
persona ve va a empujar esta caja con
una cierta dirección y con una cierta
magnitud dando este vector fuerza este
vector fuerza es el vector que me dice
la magnitud y la dirección a la cual
está empujando la persona ven esta caja
así que aquí tenemos a este vector ven
es el vector fuerza b y además también
tenemos el dato de que este vector b
tiene como magnitud déjame ponerlo aquí
tiene como magnitud una fuerza de 300
newtons de 300 newtons y bueno ahora
vayamos a los ángulos si yo me fijo en
la dirección hacia la meta tengo algo
más o menos así aquí me voy dirección
hacia la meta o ok bueno pues entonces
sabemos que este ángulo este ángulo a y
para eso déjame cambiar de color
este ángulo a es de 35 grados este
ángulo es de 35 grados ok y por otra
parte este otro vector el vector fuerza
ven tiene un ángulo de 15
se forma un ángulo de 15 grados de luz
ahora lo que quiero que hagas es que
pases este vídeo e intentes pensar
cuánto de cada una de las fuerzas va en
dirección a la meta y también quién de
las dos fuerzas está ejerciendo una
fuerza mayor en esta dirección pese a
que sabemos que la persona am tiene un
vector fuerza esta que tenemos aquí que
tiene una magnitud de 330 newtons en
esta dirección y esta persona pep tiene
un vector fuerza que tiene una magnitud
de 300 newtons en esta dirección pese a
ello lo que quiero saber es cuál de los
dos está empujando con mayor fuerza
hacia esta dirección hacia la dirección
de la meta por cuanto más y además sería
bueno saber la magnitud total de la
fuerza que está empujando en dirección
hacia esta meta
bien suponiendo que ya pausa este el
vídeo y es que la clave de este problema
es sacar las componentes de estos dos
vectores es decir la magnitud de estos
dos vectores en esta dirección es decir
con respecto a la dirección hacia la
meta y bueno qué te parece si primero
pensamos en nuestra fuerza déjame
dibujar de nuevo por acá a mi fuerza am
con este color
imagínate que por aquí tengo a mi fuerza
se ve más o menos así ok
aquí voy a dibujar que esta es mi fuerza
ok y entonces la magnitud la magnitud de
esta fuerza nosotros sabemos que vale
330 newtons así que déjame ponerlo así
330 newtons de lujo ok ahora si nosotros
nos fijamos en esta dirección como si
fuera esa la dirección hacia la meta
déjame ponerlo así estoy justo aquí y
tengo esta dirección y para acá está la
meta es decir estoy dibujando esta parte
de aquí en esta parte de aquí por aquí
en algún lugar de por acá
a la meta ok y entonces nosotros sabemos
que tenemos un ángulo de 35 grados que
este ángulo es de 35 grados ahora si yo
quiero saber la magnitud de la fuerza
que tira hacia este lado bueno pues
esencialmente lo que hay que hacer es
sacar la componente horizontal de esta
fuerza am si yo me fijo en su componente
horizontal y déjame ponerlo con este
color
bueno pues realmente no es tan difícil y
si aquí me fijo en la componente
horizontal la componente horizontal se
va a ver más o menos así y bueno esta
componente horizontal
la voy a denotar con el subíndice x y yo
lo que quiero saber es la magnitud la
magnitud de esta componente horizontal a
subíndice x que no es más que la
cantidad de fuerza de esta fuerza que
empuja hacia esta dirección hacia la
dirección de la meta y bueno para sacar
esta magnitud de esta componente
horizontal realmente no está tan difícil
lo único que hay que recordar son los
triángulos rectángulos porque si yo de
aquí bajo una línea para acá se forma
rectángulo este de aquí y entonces
podemos decir que este lado lo podemos
obtener recordando nuestras funciones
trigonométricas es decir si nosotros
recordamos un poco la definición del
cosa en el coseno de 35 grados el coseno
de 35 grados bueno pues esto es
exactamente lo mismo que su lado
adyacente pero su lado adyacente es este
de aquí su lado es decente es este de
aquí que es la magnitud de esta
componente horizontal la magnitud de
esta componente horizontal a subíndice x
ok a esto dividido dividido entre la
hipotenusa pero la hipotenusa es lo que
vale esta parte de aquí y esta parte de
aquí tiene una longitud o una magnitud
de 330 newtons de 330 newtons y si ahora
de aquí despejamos a esta magnitud que
es lo que nosotros queremos vamos a
obtener que y déjame ponerlo así que la
magnitud la magnitud que nosotros
queremos de esta componente horizontal
del vector am ok esto
exactamente igual que el seno de 35 por
330 330 que multiplica al coseno de 35
ok de lujo esta es la cantidad de fuerza
de esta fuerza la cual va a empujar la
caja en dirección hacia la meta y bueno
podemos pensar exactamente lo mismo con
la fuerza bien es más vamos a hacerlo si
te das cuenta la fuerza apunta hacia
abajo en dirección a la meta y entonces
se vería más o menos así si por acá
tengo la dirección hacia la meta más o
menos como por acá ok entonces fíjate
que esta fuerza ver se va a ver de esta
manera esta fuerza se va a ver más o
menos así ok y bueno nosotros sabemos
que la magnitud de esta fuerza y déjame
ponerlo igual la magnitud de esta fuerza
b es de 300 newtons es de 300 minutos
300 newtons ok y entonces nosotros
queremos calcular su componente
rectangular bueno pues su componente
horizontal se va a ver más o menos así
ok
esta va a ser el vector b sub índice x
como vector pero nosotros lo que nos
interesa es su magnitud su magnitud ok y
entonces date cuenta que aquí tenemos un
ángulo de 15 grados de 15 grados ok y
entonces de igual manera si nosotros nos
fijamos en un triángulo rectángulo en
este triángulo rectángulo de aquí
entonces podemos decir y dejarlo ponerlo
así que el coseno el co seno de 15
grados esto es exactamente lo mismo que
esta cantidad y déjame atraparla y
copiarlo por aquí y la voy a pegar por
acá ok esto / dividido a su vez entre
déjame cambiar de armenta entre la
longitud de esta hipotenusa que es 300
ok y ahora si nosotros queremos despejar
a este entonces nos va a quedar que este
de aquí este que es la magnitud de la
componente horizontal esto es
exactamente lo mismo
en 300 300 que multiplique al coseno de
15 que va a multiplicar al coseno de 15
y bueno es hora de saber cuánto vale la
magnitud de este vector y la magnitud de
este vector o espera este es un vector
este es un vector este es un vector y a
ver si sacamos por acá nuestra
calculadora y es hora de terminar de
resolver este problema si yo quiero
sacar primero a estoy justo por acá el
coseno de 35 ok ya esto multiplicarlo
por 330 esto va a ser igual a 270 punto
3 ok entonces pongámoslo esto es
exactamente igual que 270 punto 3 déjame
uno ver un poco la pantalla vamos un
poquito en la pantalla para camps y
entonces son newtons 270 punto 3 minutos
ahora pensemos qué es lo que pasa con la
componente horizontal de este vector ven
y para eso
cambiar de color y voy a traer de nuevo
mi calculadora
si yo traigo a mi calculadora voy a
obtener ahora el coche 9 15 grados lo
voy a poner aquí 15 grados le voy a
sacar el coche no y lo voy a multiplicar
por 300 por 300 y esto me dan 289 punto
777 si lo redondeamos es 289 punto org
lo voy a poner aquí 289 280 y 9.81 diste
cuenta está genial aunque la magnitud de
este vector b es menor que la magnitud
de este efecto ahora si nosotros nos
fijamos en la cantidad de fuerza que
ejercemos hacia la meta es mayor la que
aporta este vector ven que es la que
aporta este vector a eso pese la
diferencia en sus magnitudes y es más
esto se puede ver con una idea intuitiva
justo aquí en nuestro diagrama original
si nosotros nos fijamos en la componente
x aunque es más o menos ésta
la componente en x de este vector b es
más o menos ésta y si nosotros nos
fijamos en la componente en x de este
vector an con este color de este vector
am
bueno pues da tu cuenta que es menor es
algo más o menos hasta acá más o menos
por acá
termina esta componente en x de este
vector am y si te das cuenta es menor el
aporte de esta fuerza en dirección hacia
la meta que el aporte de esta fuerza ven
en dirección también hacia la meta y
bueno de hecho si queremos saber en
cuanto más es un aporte que el otro
dejemos sacar de nuevo mi calculadora la
puede traer por acá
ok pues habrá que tomarnos la diferencia
de este ya esto le voy a quitar a 270
punto 3 270 punto 3 ok y bueno la
diferencia entre ellos dos es 19.47 lo
podríamos tomar como 19.5 newtons es
mayor el aporte de la fuerza p hacia la
meta que el aporte de la fuerza y bueno
si nosotros quisiéramos saber en total
cuál
la fuerza que apunta hacia la meta
habría que tomarnos la suma de estos dos
vamos a hacerlo 280 y 9.8
esto le sumó 270 punto 3 y entonces en
total se da una fuerza de 560 punto 1
eso es la fuerza total que vamos a
ejercer hacia la meta incluyendo estas
dos fuerzas y además vamos a escribirlo
si yo me tomo a esta fuerza de color
verde le agrego esta fuerza
que era más o menos así de color morado
que es lo que aporta esta fuerza nos va
a dar una fuerza total que es todo esto
de aquí hasta acá es todo lo que
nosotros estamos aportando para empujar
la caja rumbo a la meta y bueno esto es
exactamente lo mismo que tomarme la
magnitud la magnitud de este vector a x
ok ya esto sumarle a éste el vector b x
ok los dos vectores van hacia la misma
dirección así que me voy a tomar la suma
de estos dos vectores y su magnitud
total es lo mismo que 500 cc
punto 1 560 punto 1 newton de lujo
aproximadamente y ya está aquí tenemos
la respuesta de este problema